the president is anointing Maxine Waters
as the face of the Democrats and many of
waters Democratic colleagues are
critical of her comments as well yet
several prominent liberal commentators
believe there is nothing wrong with
harassing political opponents tonight
Fox News media analysts and host of
Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz puts all
of this situation in context when word
spread that a Virginia restaurant had
refused to serve Sara Huckabee Sanders
some pundits those who detest president
Trump started cheering
the press secretary they said deserve
the rude treatment you'll make choices
in life and there is a cost to being an
accomplice to this cruel deceitful
administration the defining feature of a
free society is that you can tell one of
the most powerful people in the world in
your government get out of my restaurant
MSNBC contributor and Washington Post
columnist Jennifer Rubin says Trump
officials should become social pariahs
of sorts most conservative commentators
denounced the Sanders incident and
protesters confronting other Trump aids
especially after Democratic
congresswoman Maxine Waters called for
their continued harassment shouting each
other down kicking our political enemies
out of restaurants heckling them in
public may feel good in the moment but
it isn't a solution threatening women
and children what is wrong with you
people and a lot former Obama White
House aide David Axelrod drew criticism
from Democrats for taking Sanders side
writing kind of amazed and appalled by
the number of folks on left who
applauded the expulsion of press
secretary and her family from a
restaurant Trump opponents are using the
president's previous policy of family
separations at the border to justify
their in-your-face tactics and the
president's critics point to his rough
language and personal insults as in
these clips from MSNBC's Morning Joe if
you see somebody getting ready to throw
a tomato knock the crap out of would you
seriously
like to punch him in the face I'll tell
you but if Obama administration
officials had been harassed in similar
fashion it's not hard to imagine both
liberals and conservatives switching
sides the tribal warfare over the
hounding of Trump aids is magnified by a
polarized media environment and the
toxic nature of social media all this
has produced a vicious cycle that could
well spiral out of control Brett let's
hope not Howie thanks